ah ah ah ah les cherry ou pas que
yassine belattar célébrer
ça lui a si nous savons c'est un pull
qu'on met pour le f'tour
c'est le pull de thierry lhermitte dans
le père noël j'aime bien celui-là j'aime
bien ça fait plaisir parce que le pauvre
alex il m'a dit dans deux secondes c'est
à toi il sait manger comme une chômage
c'est vrai mais le pauvre élection
normale son anniversaire syrie lire tu
as parlé d'une émission dont on ne parle
jamais sur ce plateau koh lanta jamais
un nouveau jeu qui tente de faire ses
preuves
on le sait tf1 est actuellement au
tournage d'une nouvelle saison all star
de son jeu d'aventuré koh lanta à
l'occasion des 20 ans du programme la
chaîne a décidé de sélectionner les
candidats les plus populaires de
l'émission pour créer un cocktail
explosif car à la fin il n'en restera
qu'un parmi ces candidats on retrouve
par exemple témoin laurent claude ou
freddy chez les hommes et jade clémence
coumba ou candide du côté des femmes
au total vingt candidats sélectionnés à
travers les différentes saisons de koh
lanta alors moi j'aime bien koh lanta
mais c'est très occidental comme je
syrie je te dis la vérité parce que j'ai
montré kolontar nos cousins au bled il
m'a dit je vois pas ce qu'il y'a des
difficiles les vacances ici voilà et
beaucoup ça tu laisses un mois sur une
île il construit un burger king
moustapha et franchement c'est en a pas
marre de koh lanta avec tu envie de
participer
j'aimerais bien qu'il faut faire un
voile un feu de camp sur le plateau 3
hamac pour éliminer un chroniqueur tu
fais l'épreuve des poteaux ou des
frérots papier frérot qui n'est pas pro
c'est une bonne vanne ça c'est vrai que
j'écoute les économistes et vu ce qu'ils
ont prévu pour la france à partir du
mois d'octobre
koh lanta ça va venir très vite dans nos
vies j'ai lu dans les échos son lot dans
six mois on chasse des crabes à la
défense jeudi la décision c'est sûr vous
annonce si un jour je deviens candidats
de koh lanta
si je mange pas de viande pendant deux
jours moi je deviens cannibale pas oui
mais les vegan je mange sophie lamon
les gens vont dire ouais il ya de la
grossophobie vu mon poids c'est moi qui
vais être mangé le premier je vous
disais voilà il ya une deuxième chose
ici sur ce plateau hier puisque vous
avez parlé aussi d'une affaire qui a
fait beaucoup réagir
c'était cette sortie médiatique la
blague de laurent bignolas dans
télématin
[Musique]
c'est une bonne idée pour qu'il fait que
l'habitude de voler mais dans les grands
magasins seulement et comme ils sont
fermés ben voilà autant sur la shoah
alors c'est tellement gros qu'on rigole
pas la balle ou l'accolade
c'est pas le racisme à la télé ça joue
ses revenus d'où elle est venue je sais
bien qu'une partie de ma redevance va
dans des propos racistes j'ai pris
l'habitude mais là ce qui est incroyable
c'est que c'était les matins frère c'est
vrai et c'est quand même une émission tu
regardes pour réveiller tranquille en
général tu as reportage sur une prof de
musique à besançon après une absence de
défense de grenouilles en lozère et là
coup de le matin samedi 6 heures 12 tu
manges une biscotte et vous les arabes
sont des voleurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
frankel 10 heures et vous pouvez pas
atteint 9 heures ne le comprennent les
douches
alors que j'aime on dira ferrero rocher
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que son sort était déjà scellé
télévision avant mais en revanche je
connais bien laurent il est d'une
maladresse insigne surtout moi je me
suis un jour dans une interview sur mike
brant il a dit il a réussi son premier
vol à l'autre s'est défénestrée donc à
caen vous savez qu'il est comme ça sur
absolument tous donc c'est désastreux
mais ça n'est pas du racisme est pas
raciste
oui alors isabelle fais-moi pensée
frangine si un jour j'ai une galère tu
aurais nord en gros ce que tu dit
isabelle c'est qu'il est plus bête que
méchant ce n'était pas un peu ça voilà
merci beaucoup voilà
mais je suis d'un concept par laurent
bignolas regarde moi bien laisse
l'humour aux professionnels aulas laisse
le racisme aussi aux professionnels y en
a ils foncent à toute la journée c'est
un métier le racisme ça ne s'improvise
pas malheureusement
[Applaudissements]